Wow.
Well,
well go to your mom's house.
We would own surgeon,
Christina.
Alright,
we're good sex with me.
That's great. Is that where
you got to work? Work,
Bubba
snappy
likes this.
This is sexy jam.
I feel like I'm at the pool man
wants to Suntan lotion baby.
Right.
Vic submitted this song.
Take a real real song.
Now he made this himself.
He didn't use a famous djs
music and just remixed it.
Apparently that happened last week.
Oh No, this is good. I like this.
I'm surprised you didn't know that. Being
a DJ as well. Community is very tight,
but there's a lot of, you know
imposters out there. It's no Rihanna.
I'm going
to Jack my son bill
this week, Florida. Wow.
We just got that now man.
I feel like we've lost out.
I was good drag.
My son Bill
Florida. I have shows
Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
I'm being told they're
moving extremely well. Oh,
so your tickets man.
Jack,
my son fell and uh,
and uh, yeah, we'll have a good time
man. Who's coming with me? Pat House,
my good friend Pat House from Philly.
Delphia he is,
he'll be there. Um, May 20th
and 21st only two nights.
Sewer juice, New York,
otherwise known as Syracuse.
Then June 9th,
10th and 11th.
Your Ein California near right.
That's a good one.
Sometimes known as Irvine's
from vine. Yup. Um,
June 16th through the 18th
birthday.
Be canceled. He shows I'm canceling. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, it's in Gash Field Tennessee.
Um, sometimes known as Nashville. Um,
June 23rd through 25th ball sack,
New York west nut sack.
Nut sack.
I think it's better than ball sack
because it's west Nyack, New York.
Really important.
July seven through nine.
It's the funny bone.
The new one in Cincinnati factory. Liberty
Township. So it was a new one. Yeah.
Thank God Clinton, Clinton
and my clip. My panties,
Ohio. Cause that other one wasn't really
in Cincinnati. It was in Kentucky.
Yeah. Newport. And this one is an improper
Cincinnati, but sure it's liberty.
Better than needs to be.
It used to be better.
The Newport contentment.
I also added a shows
just for people to know.
July I'm doing San Diego, man, Diego,
Mandy, American comedy company.
Um,
Saint Louis is now on sale mg mommy.
And so his new pork titties,
Caroline's July eight, 10, eight, nine 10.
And then the Trocadero theatre.
It's way, way in the future.
But uh, fill her up. Delphia Pennsylvania.
It is November 19th and I was told there
are less than 80 tickets remaining for
a November show. That's exciting.
Right before the mama days. Yeah.
Uh,
what do you got genes May 27th,
may 28 at the comedy store in La Jolla,
San Diego,
La Jollan. And then, um,
you know the comedy store here
in Hollywood every Saturday,
mostly Saturday nights to seven 30 show.
I love to do that early show and
I'm working on cities like Seattle,
Portland, Denver, Mommy, Apolis uh,
where else pick Enoch's chicargo shit,
car go. All these places
you're working on the schedule.
So my age is showing that he
listens to the show. He goes,
Mike, Mike Shit. Are
you doing Mike at Uta?
Sprite Vick again, great,
great song man. This is,
this is like a legit music
songs is the shit man. Yeah,
I can sing like this. I can sing
just like Rihanna. And I consent.
All right, let's move it along. Um, no,
it's good. I'm saying it's
good. Let me hear you sing it.
If you haven't picked up Rihanna,
his new album,
it's been playing in the Sigora house
all weekend. A couple of months old. Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
Terry had the musical taste,
the 12 year old girl, whatever.
Rihanna, I guarantee you
we talked about this thing.
She didn't write those lyrics that was
written by a fat old music producer
record guy. The record
labels like, you know what?
You should do a song about fucking you
soul mate. I've always wanted to fuck you.
One second.
I saw you.
I saw those thin light chocolate frame.
Then I wanted to break it in half and
you're going to sing a song about how
great it is to fucking cause
there's no woman is like,
I'm going to write a song called sex
with me is so amazing. And then she just,
is this what you wrote? Yeah. Alright,
let's go cause it sags with me.
So how much am I getting paid
on this deal? Okay. Yeah,
it's amazing. Fuck him.
He's amazing. It's crazy.
Women don'ts and also like it's clunky.
She's like stay above my Instagram.
There's so temptation.
It's cause the guy's like,
I look at your Instagram every day and
I took off all over my house for sure.
There's no rhyming in that Rihanna album.
Numero Uno. Is it in any weeks
in a row? Wow. That was dog shit.
That is pure shit. Really? You
don't like that? I like it.
No,
it's like a,
it's like a 12 year old girls.
Listen to that shit in you and my
husband and my 48 year old husband until,
yeah.
Nice.
Sound sad. Are we ready?
Dad is already to go.
Farts. Farts. Farts. Are
you ready to start the show?
Let's do it. Let me get this here. Uh, by
the way, a lot of people were asking like,
Tom, when are you going to get a mouse?
Here it is. Couldn't get it to work.
We've got to get another one.
So what?
Dads don't always know how to use tech
thing is I turned it on and then a blue
tooth didn't wears glasses
on for this year, blue tooth.
And I
danced as it should be.
That's never know how stuff works.
They need Hell No. All right,
let me see here.
I feel you.
I know how you're feeling right now.
How much do you want to sex with Rihanna?
Have you thought about it? Um, yeah,
I want to have sex with her bed.
Do you go to her Instagram?
Like she says in the song.
Here we go. More bullshit.
All right, here we go. Here we
go. Let's start the show. Hot 97
and pawn was his hype man and Paul would
always wanna use my cell phone and I'll
be like,
I got a call radio,
I've got to call retail and
we'd have like $60 relative.
He was like $60 to eat with
two fattenings per diem. Yeah.
Christina visits in person.
Yeah.
Ooh,
big words for him.
I want to use those big words at
that station very casually to like,
he always says that you
recognize Steve Lubell here? No,
he was on an episode of
millionaire matchmaker. What
was he talking like? This?
Yeah, he was mad show, yeah.
Member. And she was like, okay,
what is your deal more?
He's a manager.
Um, what's the lot of big hip
hop acts? He's been around for,
you know, probably 30 years. Right.
And so he picks up the expectations of
the rappers and what he's like in New
York. You know, dude from just a
black guy. Yeah. Yeah. He's just,
he's just this other black guy with
the wrong fucking skin tone. Um,
and upon was his hype man.
And Paul would always want to use
my cell phone and I'll be like,
I got a call radio, I got a call
retail and we'd have like $60 relative.
He was like $60 to eat with two
fattening per diem. Yeah. And,
and wait, who's into, he was interviewing.
It doesn't sound like a black guy, right?
Well, yeah. Well they get into it
actually, you know, and the, the,
the big words and words are actually
big this weekend because Larry Wilmore,
the host of the,
the nightly show on comedy central,
he did the White House
correspondence dinner, you know,
a set where you go up and you basically
light the, you know, the journalists,
sometimes the administration on fire.
He crushed it. I mean, he was just,
he was no holds barred. Just lighting
it up in that room was not into it.
They didn't have,
like you said,
one time I did a set at the journalism
awards here in Los Angeles and I have
never eaten shit harder. I mean, and I,
this was like two or three years ago.
So I've been doing standup for a minute.
Yeah.
And events like that are very difficult.
I mean,
they dropped the dessert
just as I was going on,
but I would have eaten shit otherwise
there are real nerds at this, a dinner,
you know? Yeah. And the thing
is that, that's a room full
of like real world leads.
Yeah. Not just the press.
Right. But that's usually, it
has their senators. There's,
you know,
it's like the hosting the Oscars.
It's just like super elite people
who take themselves too seriously.
And when you have someone like Wilmore
who is digging into you really,
really lighting people up,
there you go.
This isn't poor taste because if they
don't feel like it's nice, you know, um,
and they get their feelings
hurt. But, but he ended, I mean,
let me see if I can pull up, tie
this all together. He ended, um,
thank you mister president. When I
met Larry Wilmore earlier this month,
he told me it's his dream come true to
follow the president at the White House
for a spot
president.
That doesn't make sense
here and now to live in your time,
Mr. Prince.
This is how we ended the son. A black
man can lead the entire free world.
[inaudible] when they pan to
the people that are black.
Yeah,
they always did it.
Words alone do me no
justice. Um, so Mr President,
I'm going to keep it a hundred.
You'll bury. You did it my Nigga.
Oh, why you liked it?
Obama laughed. It's cool.
There was backlash even from
a lot of people, a lot of
black people. Oh, it fell,
it was very disrespectful to say that to
the president of United shore anyways.
I didn't, I mean I'm white, but I didn't
know, but I, cause I thought it was,
it was done with a lot of affection.
I thought he, you know, it wasn't,
I mean I realize you're saying
it to the president, but, right.
But as with everything in comedy,
I think the intent is really what counts
as a black man saying it to another
black man. And he wasn't saying it the
way that other guy, I like the way.
So let's go back to, yeah, that's
a different, totally different. Um,
Steve Lowe Bell. Uh, if I'm saying, Oh,
I thought that guy was the guy
that the body guard from a,
no, we found the kid man.
50. I feel like money
guys. Steve Wilkos, uh,
Steve Wilkos looks a little bit
about Kevin's hill. Here. We got it.
Why do people stress?
Look at the president ain't
sweating the n bomb then who cares?
He was the one and only matters to make
him the president took it that way.
That this is coming from a place of
affection. Oh. And a comedian too.
We didn't hire median, but whatever,
people have the right to be forever.
But this is, this is different. This is
a little different here. So he's still,
he's doing the interview here
and he just Kinda keeps going.
No, we found a kid, man. I
made a record with 50. I feel
like money buzzing. Buzzing.
So that's been in la getting niggas
jewelry bag, holding niggas down,
discovering people, consultant people,
helping people in those real top.
You see it today,
laugh after
they're like, okay, okay.
I don't know how I'd feel to hearing him
say that stuff when I got to be like,
what? Wait. Can we pause on this? Uh,
yeah. He's, he keeps rolling. Hilly.
It's no big deal. I just dropping
bombs like his normal God. Yeah.
Yeah. He's really good at dropping
the lender Nigga a pencil. Right.
So He um,
he continues,
I think they must have obviously
at some point asked him like,
what is up with you doing this,
you know,
or why are you so part of the community?
Right.
Well I think the thing is that he
considers them, but it's a good point.
I think he does consider
himself part of that community.
I don't think he thinks that he's not,
but I don't think you're,
you're allowed really in until you meet
a certain criteria in which is being
black. Well that would be the thought
of a lot of people, but not this guy.
They just know you as like little CV.
Right? If you were in New York person,
like this is the problem. I live in La,
right. And Ami Girls. And they be like,
why do you act like Dan? Why do you
talk like that and dress like that?
Like you must have never been in New York
doing because the white are just like
me and he'd probably got tats and fight,
go to Riker's on all that.
Well I remember I told you this.
I Dunno. I mean, he's
just, he's saying like
this fucking guy.
I love when white people try to sweat
the plight the same way black people
haven't like no dude, no bro, trust
me, you're still not a Hee Hee Hee.
You're causing yourself problems at this
point. You know also implying that uh,
white people from New York or like
black people, they go to jail a lot.
That's what he just said.
Five minutes on Rikers island
and then that guy, this is what it must
be when he defended his use of it. Right.
So here it goes.
I'll walk into a room your way.
People, Russell, Russell Simmons.
So what's up my Nigga in the,
like Russell, he's, he's wife Joe.
Just so you know how to explain that
some Nigga doesn't mean a black person to
me and is a slave. Does
Mexican slaves, Jewish slaves,
black slaves, white sleeves.
I grew up, Nigga, Nigga,
Nigga. That's my Nigga in La.
Once a blood dude said to
me, Yo, you said that word.
And I was around sugar at the time and
I was in the studio without laws and
stuff.
It was a lot of guns.
It was a lot of craziness because
a lot of executives who are white,
they don't want to be around the
Hennessy to guns and the dogs.
They don't be on the tour buses.
They just want to come around to the
certain things and take the credit after
the fact and he's like, Yo, you need to
go to bank. No, you owe me 15,000 saying,
Nigga, my Nigga, you're
going to kill me right now.
And no one extorting me white niggers.
So yeah.
Do you think there's a reason that the
white executives don't come around when
there's guns and Hennessy involved?
He obviously wants to be there for that.
That's what I like.
Maybe it's not a white thing name.
It's just a thing that the
person wants to stay alive.
It doesn't hang out with Shugg
and those people. No sugars.
It is a death sentence. I want to
die, hang out with Shugg night,
even in prison and be like,
don't hang out with that dude.
We're not going to be bros.
I've seen a lot of white there in my time,
this guy.
But I love when he's trying to convince
them like I can use the word because
Russell Simmons said it to
me once and I want to be,
and then all of you were, you know, quite
a big words.
I just,
I just kills me when
you're born a white guy,
which is like top of the food
chain in America. Big words. Yeah.
Motherfucker like you're at the
top. Why? What are you doing?
You have it pretty dumb prick.
Just be a white guy. I enjoy it.
Stopped feeling guilty and weird about it.
You won the cosmic lottery asshole,
the easiest position and you're
making life hard for, you know,
saying I used to comb it.
I liked it when the,
he says that this is still again
cause he goes, he says he's hanging
out in that studio and some blood.
So some gang banger from and go to the
bank and get me $15,000 for saying that
word. Right. And then in
his version of the story,
he says it again to that
guy. Do you understand? Yes.
So his,
his version of a dude who just
a gang member who was just like,
go to the bank and get me money is that
he told that guy you're going to have to
extort me. But he used the word, but I'm
going to say it again. It's all buses.
They just want to come around. Does he
owe me 15,000 San Diego? So my Nigga,
you gonna kill it right in my, so the
guy just said, hey man, you can't stay.
They go get me money and that I'm
going to respond. I'm saying, Nigga,
I'll send my Nigga, you're going to kill
me right now. And no one extorting me.
You didn't see it did not.
Steve will goes to not say that Steve
Wilkos was with Jerry Springer every day.
He would never,
he was too busy gardening such a
psycho ridiculous shift from that guy.
But I'll finish off, finish
the yard, done. Uh, but to,
to the further the point of Larry Wilmore,
I think people, most people, I think
we're pretty okay with it, you know?
Yeah, yeah. With him saying it's comedian,
like whenever you hire a comedian
to do a job, don't get offended.
I'm just a comedian.
But I think more than a comedian,
it's a black man saying it to
another blend. Different, different,
same strokes for everybody. We all
finished. Are Y'all done? Yeah,
he sounds like he's going to cry. It is
really worth getting clowned. So hard.
So hard spec on my name that I
could hear the tremble in the voice.
Put some respect on my name.
He's going to cry.
It is my favorite thing
of the last few months.
We've been saying this for the last
week now and that run in the house.
It's great. We all are. We all finished?
Are Y'all done? We're done. Um,
the Hamiltones man, y'all
finish. Y'All done? Uh, you know,
uh, what's it called?
The occupier loans. Yeah.
These guys are on the tour bus
and they just like improvise a,
a song based on that interview.
It's amazing.
These guys just on binary or non binding.
These guys I think are binary. Yeah.
What'd you do? My hair
just went out. Yup. Yup.
What's going on? We're good.
We're back. Okay. Oh, guys
are binary. These are buying.
I don't, I only listened
to nonbinary means, okay,
this will be a challenge for you.
I want you to bloody out Australia.
Don't listen when you say my name on it.
I ain't gonna say it. And I will say
no. Listen, I'm going to pull it up,
but that ain't
no,
I'll be finished
tree
on it
and I will say no.
Unbelievable. That's amazing. Wow.
They were so good. That was so good. I
thought that was Hugh more for a second.
Yeah. Right. And it looks like him.
I haven't seen that guy around.
I don't see that in a minute, but he's
hilarious. Yeah. That's so good, man.
Wow.
Put his bag, man. Put
some respect on my name.
He is going to cry like a bitch. What do
you think his wig his room like? Correct.
I hope he gets a window.
You saying that we care about how is
he gonna come in here now and I didn't
expect my Mac.
Okay.
Bitch SPEC.
It isn't gonna roll in here with seven
to his homies and your mom's done came in
into your mouth.
She could have came up to the
cabinet stove thanks to oh no.
Yo House, Christina. Bulimics key.
All right. All right. Sorry. I'm sorry
bird didn't put respect on your name.
Respect, respect it or SPEC. Oh shit man.
Like I got clown pretty fucking
hard. Oof. Yeah. Still getting clown.
It's still happening. Yeah.
He's got a clown by us again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. For sure,
man. Or Guy. He, he'll be all right.
Believe me. He'll be thinking, so yeah.
How do you recover from it?
That's become like an internet.
He's worth $150 million. Yeah, he's
fine. He's fine. He's not gonna.
He'll be chilling. Oh, why
bother? I think that get,
what gets me is that he bothered to come
in to the radio show and then he didn't
have,
there's also a level of of what he
did that even though there's no direct
threat, there's a perceived threat
and then that's what he's company.
He knows that when he looked at,
well, he was walking out of there,
that those people were at least
like Jesus. Oh, right. And that's,
and then you could tell even Charlemagne
afterwards, like, you know what,
I'm good at. Charlemagne.
I don't need any more. Uh,
I don't need to interview him again.
We're all good. Everything's good. It's,
it's a way to say like, I'm not
fucking with you. All right. Right.
Like we're good man. No, Charlemagne, you
mean the medieval King Charlemagne, right.
I meant the God that was sitting at the
breakfast club. Oh, okay. Charlemagne,
yeah. Not As unconquered. Right hand.
Different guide from the
medieval renaissance period.
South Carolina born and got
you. Yep. Okay. Anyways,
so fucking jacked up, dude.
It's been a great week. Um,
we got a lot of positive
feedback on, um, uh,
Tom and I discussing the
shower that we took together.
There's been multiple
showers before and after now,
but I was at the store and I'm red
band came up to me and was like, oh,
what a great episode. He goes, but
I have to ask you, are you serious?
When you say that Tom Spreads his butt
cheeks and puts it up against the water.
And I'm like, yeah,
no, that's a real move.
And then my friend Eric texted
me the same thing. Like, wow,
that is a bear marking his territory. It
sounds like he's trying to dominate you.
Yeah.
Which by the way,
I'm used to it being your word. I'd
never heard that. No, it's not a real,
it's a talking a loogie and I know that.
So don't fucking email me and tell me
what I'm doing wrong. I say it's hawking.
It just sounds,
that's a better word for me.
That one makes me want to vomit and
Snowdonia snot rockets. Not Ross.
It's really nice in your beard.
And then I peed on us. That's,
but that's so standard issue.
I thought that was what everybody
in any relationship. Well Brian,
when his friend who's name
I can't remember, sorry, but
she, she was saying that,
is that true that he pees on Youtube?
I go, yeah man, is it that crazy?
And she's like, I've never been pinned
on. I'm like, won't come over to my House,
my pee on you two lady.
I feel like that standard issue
in a really thought that was,
I thought that everybody does everyone,
but actually you're the first boyfriend
that ever peed on me in the shower,
so I wasn't dating savages know you
were dating some nonbinary people.
Can I tell you that? But before
I dated you, I was the man.
Like people thought I was gross.
Like all my boyfriends would have
to tell me to stop picking my nose,
stop farting and burping like my last
boyfriend before you. Zero tolerance,
zero tolerance for it towards the end to
really fucking hated it when I wake her
up and fall.
When someone doesn't love you anymore
and you're burping and farting,
you think that she goes over? No. Oh
my God, you guys are so disgusting.
You're lucky.
I love you as much.
But you set the bar so low for disgusting
behavior low or has a high high that I
never have to strive Trump to grocer.
Are you really asking me that question?
Yeah, no, I know. I know. I know,
I know. I totally know. Do you know
how disgusting you are? Not really.
I just feel like it's normal.
When we started dating,
you had no soap in your shower and
shampoo and you use that on everywhere.
Just everything. But you can use
shampoo. Suds is soap. Why can you not?
You can.
Most people choose not to.
What am I do go to the store.
Buy Soap too.
Most people do. No, that's fine. Did you,
when I asked you to buy
soap in your shower,
were you blown away or are you
like this bitch? I was just like,
I don't understand why you're
not using all the shampoo I got.
I got all the shampoo and the best part
is to like the cap was loose on that
shampoo bottle, so water would go
into it and dilute it. So it was like,
but that memory can last longer. You
get more, more shampoo, more soap.
I'm really going to get my ass wax.
I've been talking to you about a
savage I know or maybe lasered, right?
Didn't we talk about that?
Cause I don't do either to my
junks I would say go for laser.
Why not? Why? Why keep
going back to get it waxed?
Like just bite the bullet and just
really had some breakthroughs, you know,
thinking about how much more of
my life I could get back with it.
And it's talking about asshole.
Well I just feel like there's just so
much time spent and people have told me,
you know they waxed their asses and it's
like one wife to wipes. They're done.
That's when my world is something now
at the big day it's even less. Yeah.
Well I sit there now. Oh Shit.
Hit the bid day on. You didn't,
you didn't hit the button. Nobody knows
what's what segment that says Oh yeah.
Fused and like what's going on.
Right.
You look like booker at the
belching contests right now.
You're so proud of yourself. So
sorry, let's go back to the topic.
Yeah.
Now I just,
I hit the water and I just let that
spray sit there but I'll let it spray for
a minute. I hear you. I know. Yeah. No,
I literally hear you and living
room cause that turtle it,
I can hear what happens in there.
That's what it really neat blessing in
all our homes is that I've always been in
close proximity to where you
shit so I can hear everything.
You hear the bedroom one? No, no, just
that downstairs. The downstairs one. Yeah.
So I hear the water going for a long time.
Yeah.
And then you always come out and you go,
whew.
And then and then when I ignore you,
you go, you're not going to ask me.
You're going to, you're not going to
ask me. And I go, how is your shit?
You say the same kind of thing to me
though. You'll be like, I don't want,
you want to know what happened?
And you play coy.
Oops.
You're wearing your oopsies around the
house to they with mood nannies here.
Those fell down.
Oopsies I don't think so.
She wants to Skygen Bald. She goes,
what? I'm serious though. Gee,
do you really want to get your ass wax?
Are you being serious? Being serious?
Because I've been thinking about seriously
how much time I spend or like when
I'm not home. Oh my God,
I'm not home and fucking,
I mean like,
you know,
public airport got disaster,
man.
Just mad in there and it gets into the
hand and your smear, when you wipe,
you're smashing it into the Harris.
So gross it as though the hairy ass.
What does the hair for? Why does
it even grow them? I don't know.
Because the women don't have
hair. I mean some I don't. Yeah,
but for you, if you're a hunter to
gather and you're out in the wilderness,
you got to cover your
asshole like naked humans.
I'm saying primitive man who
was out hunting and gathering.
Women don't need it because we're
with the babies and the cave.
But you're out there with
leopards chasing you.
You could sit down on a rock and a snake
could crawl right up your ass and lay
eggs. This is probably to
cover. Okay, so this is,
this is a real explanation I'm offering.
Know I saw this on Nat Geo.
Why does Tom Cigarettes asshole
have hair on the next episode? Well,
I'm going to go reverse.
I think you should.
So is your butthole hair like your beard
because at that full the whole hair
isn't so crazy. It's the
inside the crack. She cared.
You know like the cheeks aren't that Harry
when it's like you spread the sheikhs
and I've seen it. Forest. Yeah, you've
seen it. Well everyone's like it's a nice,
isn't that it's hot.
It's so hot as anything.
I've heard that it really
makes it a lot less hot.
Sexy, high. I know it's
going to stay sexy,
but temperature was well cause when we
did Nikki glazers show not safe and we're
talking about pegging and she's like,
do you even put your finger up there?
And I'm like, so hot is hot
and steamy and hairy and scary.
It's a gross place.
Had a lot of diarrhea today and
you really did.
The nice thing about diarrhea with that
per day is that you hit that water and
you go with paper later. There's nothing
left. There's nothing there. I know,
cause I had some loose ones
too. I say I have a, I had like,
I have like a five. Yeah.
The day cleans it right up.
You was you as total seven.
I had about a 6.5649999999999995.
It was pretty bad.
It was pretty much blew. Really loose,
loose meat sandwich all the way. Yeah.
It kind of made you sit there and go,
you know,
I just liked, I just liked
playing that come in those balls.
Why am I so low? I feel like I'm a
child and you're an adult. Go. You are
so gross
and you'd grow up.
Shut up. I grow. When I
look at you, I throw up.
You just want to fuck me and
then go to your mom's house.
Wow. She sounds binary though. She does.
They,
I prefer prefer them to be non binary.
I only watched nonbinary pornography,
so anyway. Yeah, a lot of
positive feedback on your,
on the shower that we took together.
You and I took a little time together
this week and we went to the Getty Museum
and that was nice to spend
time with you like that.
We never really get to do things
like that. I know it was a,
it was thoroughly enjoyable.
We just walked around the Getty.
If you ever come to Los
Angeles and you want, you know,
cities have their leave their mark right
with their cultural stamp of hey we,
you know, we invest in, in making
these arts destination. Yeah. Yeah.
And the Getty is really impressive.
There's actually two Getty's in La.
The more prominent one is right off
the four oh five and it's massive
multibillion dollar museum
that has gardens and you know,
as it's one of the
world's great art museums.
It does have food if you want to eat
while you're at the museum. I mean,
the leading thing that they,
that they promote is their food,
but it also has [inaudible] and you can
get one. Yeah, you can get wine, coffee,
you can get coffee and you can
go to the bathroom. And then, um,
which is really pretty,
or you can see they're
world class art sculptures,
paintings,
just they have a rotating works of art.
They had a photography exhibit
that we saw, a photography,
photography and they have pictures there,
pitchers and pitchers that a photographer
took and they're framed and hanging on
the wall. How many people say photographer
constantly. I hear it all the time.
I heard my sister when she was out here
say x specially really hit it hard.
You know what I mean?
Like especially,
especially, yeah, she does. I've
heard of those. I just let it go.
K Express. Okay. Hitler. Uh,
but I love the Getty.
We saw Robert Maplethorpe exhibit the
explain for Koller explain who that is.
So Mabel Thorpe was the
photographer, photographer,
famous in the late seventies,
eighties took portraits of famous people,
most notably like Patti Smith for the
cover of horses, which is a huge album.
And the, and, and, and then he
took other types of photos. Yeah.
Well, you know, he was, uh,
he was pretty binary
and he was actually by,
for a while.
Patty Smith is a woman.
And then later he decided, he was
like, Nah, I like the other stuff more.
And then he died of Lecia. But, um,
but some of those photographs or,
uh,
provocative, Ooh. Say for instance,
there was one where you walk into a room
at the Getty and then you see just kind
of torso, mid torso down. Um,
a man in a suit,
but it's flies open and you won't
believe what's hanging out of his fly.
It's a massive, I would
say semi erect. Right.
Lack on circumcise.
Mm.
And uh, yeah, if everyone's just
walking around salivating and you know,
trying to put their saliva
back in their mouth.
But there was some provocative photos
but you pointed out to me that his most
controversial and provocative photos,
we're not in the know and I'm a little
disappointed in the Getty that they
didn't Kinda, they didn't go go
there. Yeah. They one JV squad. Yeah.
Cause I worked at a bookstore in the 90s
when I was in college and if you wanted
to see Maplethorpe's books,
the book of work,
you had to show id that you were over
18 and it was behind the counter. Yeah.
And immediately off. Right then
you couldn't drop off right there.
You had to buy it and take it home.
Yeah.
But I remember being like whatever this
book is, I'm on board cause no one,
the anarchist cookbook was behind the
counter and I'm able for book and those
are my two favorite books. When I worked
at the bookstore in Woodland Hills. Yeah.
And uh, so Mabel Thorpe, I don't know
if you want to Google image search,
just show the people.
Okay. I can't show it on,
I'm on Youtube is going to get flagged.
Google Thorp and just look
at the treasures. Yeah.
Maplethorpe Maplethorpe's m a. P.
P. L. E. T. H. O. R. P. E. Yeah.
Robert. You might have to
start, you don't have to,
you'll see some like naked people.
You're like, that's it. No, it gets,
it gets better. Yeah. Keep
digging. Yeah, keep going.
I've seen naked people maybe not
like this. You haven't special.
Yeah. Uh, yeah, but I was
disappointed that they didn't
go full maple for upon it.
Yeah. I mean that's kind of
what people want to see. Right.
If you want to know where's the com,
it should have been at the Maple Thorp
exhibit. They really should have been.
And they,
they dropped the ball on that for sure.
But we saw all somewhere
standing. Yes. It's,
you have to take a tram to get to the
Getty and you park down below and they
take you up a hill.
It's really alive.
That's the Maple Thorp exhibit o
okay.
I should have been playing the audio part
of the installation. Right. He's sure.
Yeah. As you walk, you
shouldn't play this. Yeah. Yeah.
Why did they do an audio component?
Yeah.
Come on.
That's art. Yeah, it's good.
Yes sir. That's art. Um,
stone sheep.
Go ahead.
So we're waiting in line to get on the
tram and we saw a little 20 year old
girls and it's funny cause, yeah, there,
and it was a cold day in la. You get to
wear a sweater or jacket. It was cold
and people don't understand.
I think that live in other parts of
the country that it does get, you know,
brisk. Yeah. Uncertain
days, you know, it'll be,
you might be used to it if you live
in a really cold city, but it's,
it gets to the point
where people wear jackets.
Well,
especially when we were in the,
in the mountains there the wind blows and
blows and you know, it's cold as fuck.
But there's always young
girls shivering in La.
Horrors are always cold no matter
what whores get cold because it's more
important to them for you to know that
they're whores, they're sexy. Warm. Yeah.
Yeah. And they're addressed like horrors.
Yeah. And I'm like, why the Getty?
You got to address it.
But I guess maybe the Maple Thorp Exhibit,
they went to go see Dicks,
but um, but yeah, I dunno.
I don't think those girls were
looking for those now. No.
What were they looking for it? I
don't know. But they definitely,
they're shivering a little chickens in
line put in work to be a whore. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Once I drink,
that's a universal truth,
man. Whores are always cold.
Always cold. Yeah. Especially, I
remember when I did Indianapolis,
I did a crackers in broad,
broad ripple once,
when winter and it's cold
and it's, yeah. Oh yeah.
And it's in that bar area
where all the kids are. Yeah.
And I just a stack of horse
around the corner, just all,
and it's snowing outside.
Crazy. It is not a joke. You
see it any, if you go Friday,
Saturday out in any city,
yeah. You'll always see those cold
hookers walking around. I know. And the,
the heels you got to where you're hitting
your hooker heels and you gotta be
cold and Chevrons. Airports. Yeah. Oh,
he's wearing like eight inch stilettos
and your leg, not the fly, right? Yeah.
In the morning. I know the morning
flight and you appreciate the effort.
You're like you're a hardworking
hooker. But yeah. You know, uh,
you don't have to do this for a
flight. No. Okay. Comfortable. Yeah.
Get countable bitch yet. And then the
tight clothes you're wearing this to,
to sit, to sit uncomfortably on
this flight. So fucking weird.
And then you land and it's still
fucking early wherever we went.
And like you don't have to look
like this til tonight, right, man,
I dunno how much you suck sucking
it at the airport, you know,
stuck at the airport, given a little
suck, suck at the airport, you know,
it doesn't matter. We, we
can't get away from it.
And, um, it's, it's obviously, you
know, the show's gotten more popular.
We know that.
Um,
but it's taken on a life of its own
and places you don't even expect it to,
to get picked up here
is, um, Rick Ross. Nope.
But I did go to high school with him
for a year. Yeah. Yeah. For a year.
He's got a really full
beard. I like that. He does.
He almost had that when he
was in seventh grade. No Shit.
And one of those dudes sound yeah. His
Dad a famous baseball player. No kidding.
Yeah.
Prints
the older Hitler so far today
Yoder, Hitler, Hitler, Hitler,
Hitler.
Hmm. I like that blue van and
do that. Oh, that was like,
it was really funny. Yeah. Yeah.
So there you go. And Prince fielder. Wow.
I didn't know he was an
anti Semite to well that,
I think the announcer was making it
clear what he was, you know? Yeah.
Very good.
Yeah. Yup. It's there, man. It's
out there. It's out there. Um,
another fun thing we saw at the Getty
was the guy in line two, we are awaiting,
oh my God,
isn't this not your favorite guy who's
got the horseshoe balding pattern and
it's all gray. It's all gray. Yeah.
He's a total dad. 50 some years old.
It's still kind of trying to keep it cool.
He was wearing his chuck Taylors right?
No faded.
The Light Blue Denim is light
blue denim was on his dad jeans.
Did he have belt on? A Brown braided?
I'm not sure. He had an untucked shirt,
a button down so you couldn't
see his belt. I remember.
Okay. And then, um, you know,
he had his, his, his vision is not
so good. He has glasses like dads do,
eh, I can't see this art. And then he, um,
yeah, he had Sasha with her, with him. Uh,
she was at least 20,
if not 30 years younger than yeah.
Way Out of his league.
Looks White. Yeah. Just
way out of his league.
And you could just have a lot in
common. Well, that's the thing when,
you know, I've seen Carl with
so many girls and he's just, he,
him and Sasha together, they're
just, it's like, you know,
they're meant to be, you can't even
tell that there's an age difference.
Like when you hang out with them
and you kind of, you go, I mean,
they might as well be the same age because
he really comes alive when he's with
her.
And I've just never seen him so happy
and it's just fun to see him finally find
the girl that's perfect
for him. So crazy. Right.
It's fucking the weirdest.
You think he's not embarrassed.
They should be embarrassed, but they're
not. And you're like, oh, I know.
And the embarrassed what he's like,
Eh,
he probably walked right that
she was totally like, she
has a little bit of like,
hmm. Yeah, he started, he had a,
he's a venture capitalist and things kind
of worked out so it worked out with us
too. So we should point out
that they were like kissing.
Yeah. Modeling and doing odd of PTA.
The whole like, I'm wrestling in India.
Yeah. You're like, what in the fuck? And
he was probably, do you like the getting,
she was like, what's that? Yeah, but
oh, by the way, the other Getty is,
I'm in Malibu and it's uh, it's
not as well known. It's phenomenal.
It was a private residence.
It's this, uh, what is it,
John Paul Getty. Um, what's that,
that architectural style though, bro?
Co Roman Roman style?
I don't know. I don't,
I have never been to that one in
the, in the Malibu Roman. It's a,
it's a multimillion dollar. Very
impressive. And they have a lot.
You could buy it from me and they have
all the Arthur you could buy the art for
me too. I'll do that. I'll just take
out a loan. I'll do that for you.
You probably take out like,
I don't know,
$500 million loan.
Do you think your,
will you take your second
wife to the Getty? Um,
when you get your Sasha,
when you done me and then you,
you have great to your 20 year old. I'll
go, you like the gay, she'd be like,
yeah, it did. He just do
a song with Rihanna. I was
like, this is a different guy.
She was like, I'll check them
out and then we'll go. Then
all of us, it's art. Why?
Because people make art. Ah,
that's nice. I have that.
That's pretty expensive when you buy it.
I think it's for sale.
I think that, can I
have it daddy? I want to
catch it. Whatever you
want. So retarded. Yeah.
I think my dad's had a few of
those. Oh my God. For sure.
That's probably why I'd notice it
cause I'm like, I don't, there's,
my dad has definitely. Why you notice it
here it goes, is 20 year old girlfriend.
Um, by the way, do you
remember one of the biggest,
um,
shows we've ever had was
a Miami fart machine?
No, it was, where is it?
It was a foreign
Barnett's
voice in the conversation or nearly free,
Ya know,
for, Ya know. So, and there was no,
there's basically no indication of
how things happened, you know? Um,
I mean, so listen to, uh,
let's see if we can get for free year
now for free. You're now free young. Now.
Don't play it my mommy
phones. Okay, go. Okay.
Sex with me.
So amazing.
Deseret. And people are free to believe
whatever they read, but you know,
I mean clearly what I've
been going through, I know
it's not psychogenic as lie.
I hope by now you've probably noticed
Jennings spoke with a foreign accent that
she'd never had before. I'm from Ohio.
I should not be talking like this.
There's no way a flu shot can
cause someone's accent to change.
Absolutely not one more. She's
claiming a flu shot. Horseshit.
Notice when inside edition first
approached Jennings in this parking lot,
she seemed to be walking normally,
but after their interview,
she walks to her car sideways saying
it was Dystonia when kcal nine
news. Isn't that the best thing
you've ever seen? Walking sideways.
And she was like a flu shot.
Flu shot there. They still buy.
Wow. That was really good. That was,
I got my flu shot and I told him, oh,
okay. Out of it. Totally not gaze.
What a lying liar.
Fucking liar.
Liar pants lie a little slut.
I think it is a little slut.
You're such a fucking, uh,
I think it is big as well. Just put your
fucking high heels on slide. She needs,
she's wearing way too many
clothes for them. Sluts.
Gotta wear horror it up a little.
Take off that jacket.
Show us your arms man. Um, foreign accent.
Speaking of foreign accents,
how not to actually, this is a,
a reporter and as a master of actions.
I really appreciate this.
This a reporter is interviewing some
soccer hooligans after an arsenal match
like soccer hooligan.
So silly. They're so,
they're so fucking gangster with how
much they love their, yeah. Their soccer.
Let's see what we can hooligans if you
can with these. Ruffians are up to,
here we go.
Also fancy TV. Really disappointed
today. Yeah. Again, I mean
I love that. I'm sorry.
I need to everybody, it's just like I've
seen it over and over and over again.
That sort of performance that I saw today
where we've had nearly all the game.
It's almost like it's just
a training game, right?
Not taking shots on guy guys.
Yeah.
Normal obviously. Yeah. But then
I mean it's so disappointing.
Yes.
It's the same ting blood every week,
blood every week,
fun every week.
Blood,
blood and Fam. I love it. I didn't
know that fam was international.
I thought that was totally us thing. I'm
not him. I don't even know that. Jesus.
You're so white fam. Yeah.
Well as in family. Yeah, fam.
Yeah, but no, but you hear it more
here. I'm saying never heard it here.
Never heard that. Yeah. Do
you have any friends of color?
No. No. I'm saying did the
fence. The fence is dead blood.
What's Paul doing? Blood. He has no eight
while I was doing, he's a sideman fun.
He sits on the bench.
He's doing nef implant.
Yeah. No, I'm with fired. I've
never heard that. Really? Never Fam.
Like good to see you fam. Nothing like
that. No, no, no. Did you think fam?
Nothing like that. I mean, I don't
say it. It would sound absurd,
but I've heard it a lot.
People have said it to me.
Steve Wilkos probably says it all
the time. We come with through fam.
You won't be there. Yeah,
no, I don't know. Fuck.
You had his number too involved
in the team. Blood or Fan? Fergie.
Fergie.
Okay.
Dennis, I want to paint you fed. You had
his number too involved in team blood.
We've all, Bowman has, he got
blood on you see the defense fund?
I love how interchangeable he is. He
goes, blood, family, blood, family,
blood fam, fam, fam, fam blood.
And as he got blood, blood,
digital go digital go. But Oh
yeah. He's thought utilize a donor.
I'll show you why it's, I don't know yet.
Donor 20 minutes after that. After that.
Yeah. I don't know who he took up, but
you took a a man in the same position.
Blood.
Okay.
That's so British to, to to end a
sentence with yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh yeah.
Plan. Why don't we pick it
up that affectation never.
We got picked up here that
we have speaking. Um, I think
I do it sometimes. Well,
yeah. Is Essentially, you know what I
mean? You know him. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's totally, yeah. Yeah. Is,
yeah, cause you know what I'm saying?
Hungarians do that though. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. You say? Yeah, in a, in Peru,
my cousin saying mine. Yes. What does
that mean? That's the slang for you.
You follow me? You feel me? Yeah.
Mine. Yes, man. Yes. Yes. Hello?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] well they have a
lift to none of them may have said that.
Dale, my f man. Yes. I
just realized I do have a,
Oh my God Dad,
that his dad had a mouse this whole time.
That as a mouse for the other, but
that's from, for this one. God Damn it.
So we dad, can he use that for this
one too? I mean the Mesas yeah,
we should probably get another
one, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Dad needs a mouse for every computer.
You know, from where I was saying that,
it looked to me like I've
terrible gold peak America.
Goalkeeping that you said it was just
like the first game of the season blood.
This is near post phone call.
It could be a new post blog
and it's done everything.
And then he did you understand
in a salad? Yeah, fam. Yeah.
Bam. You understand? Yeah. But look
how bummed this guy is just he's so,
he can't even bring yourself for words.
You so upset.
I was so bummed that he doesn't get to
talk. Yeah, I think that's what he's like.
Wonder if he'll ask me. He's like,
Hey, the whole time he's like, well,
he asked me a question.
You think? I think so,
but then this guy also knows that this
guy is great for PV blood. This guys,
I could listen to them talk all day.
Yeah.
I man just said Dave is a confidence
thing. Like I said in my interview before,
motivation, blood, the
team is not doing it again.
We'll quite get what she could walk again.
So fun.
I think doing robot come for five minutes,
but what did he do?
Black called? What's the point?
Blood is getting tagged from behind.
He's Tarot Ball.
What are they doing in the portrait?
We come up with five minutes,
but what did he do? Blood Park.
What's the point back off?
What's this man doing?
What he doing in the board
does not motivate. Get blood.
They're not doing that
and that walk out again.
We'll kind of get what you
give me a black eye robot.
Where does that come up for five minutes?
But what did he do call?
What's the point? What's this man doing
fun? What are you doing in the board?
But she's a crazy guys.
Amazing.
Yeah, I love it. I love
soccer. Hooligans and crazy.
You're like, you know,
I can't take it anymore.
I just want to hear the best of what
this guy has got. Well, we got that from,
oh good,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
It has to stop.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh Shit. Oh man, that was good. Good
work. Blue Band. Really good job.
That's really good. Blah
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So soccer hooligans or like the,
the British version of like our
football lunatic paint there.
I think they're definitely crazy.
Are There Derek? That they're crazy.
They riot and the people up in
there as Harris. Yeah. Yeah.
But they're way more amusing to
listen to then it was pretty,
I mean there's those guys
pretty much holding it. He's
animated. He fired up that,
but his team losing.
But there's definitely,
I don't even know if he would
constitute a hooligan, you know,
hooligans over there. Really.
They're terrifying. Yeah.
Get big groups and they're
like breaking shit. Yeah.
Throwing Molotov cocktails and
yeah, they're, they're not man.
Bill Hicks had a great bit
about soccer hooligans.
He was saying that they weren't like,
um,
the biggest thing in England is a waste
bin was knocked over in Shaftsbury.
So cute. Where are the
hooligans? Like their,
their musicals maybe after he did
that, but things change. I know.
That was like in the nineties yeah.
You believe that dude died at like 34.
I know.
It's crazy.
And do you know that Hicks
toward while he was dying? Yeah.
And his last stuff he recorded,
it was as he was dying,
he told no one that he was, he told very
few people that he was dying of cancer.
Wow.
So crazy.
Could you imagine doing like that's
what you choose to do at the end of your
life? I don't know. I might still do
standup. Yeah. I mean he also, you know,
he's a single guy and you
know, he didn't, it was,
we're going to do just sit at home.
And was he married? No, he had a woman,
but I don't know if they're only worried.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, you know. Yeah,
I've looked it up and his
name wasn't married. Oh, okay.
No problem with that. I feel like you
wish you could have married Bill Hicks.
Yeah. You love his stuff.
Why would I marry Bill Hicks
when I'm married? A savage?
Who knows? And I married a dirt devil.
Burt dog. He might've been a savage. No,
no. Bill Hanks. He's kind of polite and
he is sweet. I don't know. I don't know.
Yeah, no, I like you. I'm glad
I married you. Yeah, yeah.
Oh,
Ooh.
Oh did you, that was bill
Hicks is ghost. It was.
We were just talking about him and then
our, our boards just fell. You see that?
That goes to bill Hicks came back
together. This guys. He's like,
bitch, he told you I love you. Fuck
it. You do love him. I do love books.
He was one,
I think one of the grades.
No, he just said hello.
He did say hello. Good.
Good for you. Yeah. Um, oh,
this is pretty great. Um, I've,
I was, somebody sent me this,
you know,
there's nobody more,
I dunno who's left a bigger impact on me,
I feel like in my life.
Um, and, and how I try to
choose, I try to live my life.
Then I'm Steven Seagal.
Um,
everyone feels the same. Most people feel
the same way. Everyone feels that way.
Here is the coaster.
Segal,
um, in this, I guess it was an
interview with a French language.
Okay.
Media people. So it starts off with
a little tease here of his, uh,
yes.
Oh shoot. Bulls are secrets. Antonio
Machado. And also shake on him.
Patricia's on the BBC Denali.
I went, there we are with their face.
Super.
All right.
I'm gonna vomit.
That was so gross I said to have been
able to throw up. I can't hear it again.
More. Yeah, I think
I've played here. Yeah.
Wait time ago. Probably
was a long time ago. Yeah.
Okay. What are your relations
with Rw today? I mean,
you know, I don't live in
Hollywood. No, I just leave. I live,
you know, in Arizona and you
know, all over the place.
I'm gonna answer it. Where do you live,
motherfucker? It's simple and you know,
all over the place. He's a
citizen of the world, Tom. He is,
he has that world passport.
He's a widow's peak of the world and
been most deaf and they just, they don't,
they live with it.
Yeah. I mean, I still have a relationship
with Hollywood. I just don't live there.
Oh, I'm going to throw up if I know I'm
doing that while I use it to place not
really healthy
for me.
It's not so good, you know, rather,
you know, why did he go eat accented
there? Right. He picks up good. You know,
how'd you say the versa?
The act, as I just said,
I'm going to borrow this. You know, God,
because the savage long experience that
many of them do and many of them don't.
Oh,
that's a great
many of them do. Many of them
people feel that way. Many do, man.
I don't many of them.
Yeah.
Do you have
to say about the crew?
The team, but the scripts. Oh Jesus.
Are you on the quiet?
No.
On the movies I do.
I have some say so in all of that,
how do you think,
what an asshole?
Just answer the fucking question.
Something tells me it doesn't want to be
there. I don't, I don't know what it is,
but I think he doesn't want to be there.
He doesn't want to
press teaches said, well,
I don't know how they came,
but they did come and I
accepted it because I wanted
to try something different.
Different of Voluma. Right,
right, right. Yes. Yeah.
Skeet. Shoot. I said chip
at bargain with that.
[inaudible] would you like
to do to come back and to be,
you know, the master of your own
project to do he have, you know,
the,
the dream of
you can tell she's really trying
to earnest. Yeah. I'm like,
I have to these really like thought out.
Yeah.
I really want to get to
know your answer on this.
I really tried to construct this in a
way that you can take it from there.
Awesome movie. That would be
the movie of your life. Yeah.
I would love to come back and make
more movies that are great movies.
Huh? He's sick. That's why he's miserable.
He's taking his theraflu and he's like,
oh,
it's so much wrong.
I think we should watch all of his movies
dubbed over in French. Yeah, we should.
I feel like that makes it way better.
Oh,
they're much better when you don't hear
him actually speak. It's great. Yeah.
We started to watch a movie of
his on Netflix number for X.
I'm sorry, I mispronounce it all the
time. Uh, we got, how far did we get?
10 minutes. It was a new one.
Yeah. Yeah. It was really bad.
It was shot somewhere in Bakersfield,
but it was meant to look like Afghanistan.
Who was, um, yeah, it was, it was,
it was shot in like Milwaukee.
You could tell. Yeah,
that's Midwest. Yeah.
Clearly the trees and Michigan's right
there. And he's just like, it's so,
so tough out here in Afghanistan.
Yeah. So, hmm. So ridiculous.
Um,
so it's been a minute and um,
it's definitely one of the most
important segments we do on this show.
Let's bring it to you right now
with a new introductory. So, wow.
Here we go.
Well,
I get to take on our
original dental update music.
It's called lost them shit by the ducts.
You can hear like the
influence of the original,
take her to the ticker type thing.
Um, do you have a dental updates?
I have a couple. Yeah. Um,
personally I'm really slacking
on a couple things. It's hot.
My flossing has not been as good lately
and I really need to white. And again,
I have my trays. Dude, I tell you to
whitening. Every time I see you smile,
I go,
look at those yellow
lottery,
your sex.
Can I tell you every fucking time I see
you smile to hug that the meanest thing
somebody could say to their spouse,
I'm trying to help. You're the worst.
So look how white my day that
I'm going to,
I want to talk about tonight. Let's
do it tonight. Yeah, I'll help you,
but we know where your trays are. I got
them in the closet. Yeah, you guys do it,
dude.
Seriously,
it's going to burn like hell but really
it hurts so bad but you look so pretty.
All right.
Hello mommies.
I am currently sitting in the parking lot
of the dentist's office after my first
visit and over 13 years.
I lied to the dentist,
told him it'd been five years because I
could not bring myself to admit to him.
Should have been over a decade after
my first visit. After my visit.
You were the first people I wanted to
share this news with much like my actual
mother.
I'm sure you are quite disappointed to
hear that one of your own head ignored
their oral health for so long, but good
news. There is nothing to worry about.
After 13 years I am cavity fruit loud.
Never had one in my life
and didn't require anything
beyond a standard cleaning.
I'm not sure if I dodged a bullet and
this will put me back on the right track
to proper dental care or if I just
reinforce my terrible behavior now that I
know it can avoid the dentist for a
third of my life and still be just fine.
Only time will tell.
Although my dental care may fall behind,
my genes will always stay high and
tight. We're too your mom, Bridget.
Uh, that was just, I mean that
is, yeah. Bridget, here's,
here's what I'm going to say. You did
dodge a bullet and I'm guessing you're,
I so I think so, but you can't
do this stuff when you're older.
That's the problem is when you
get into your forties and 50s.
She's in her thirties. But, but yeah,
as you get older it will get more serious
and I would consider myself just lucky
on that one. If, if I was her, uh,
we got another one.
Let's see. Hey, Mommy's,
I finally went to the dentist for the
first time in 10 years. Last week guys.
Boy was this embarrassing. After 26
years, I still have a baby tooth.
The original adult tooth group backwards
into the Palette of my mouth and was
removed the last time I saw a dentist
10 years ago along with my five wisdom
teeth and it's falling apart.
Along with that,
one of my showing teeth right up
front is broken in Hass slant ways.
That's what I had and seven small cavities
throughout the rest of my mouth. Oh,
Holy Shit. Right. My dentist
literally gave me a d plus grade,
so the fillings are covered by insurance,
but to get the crowns
it's like $900 a tooth.
Can have the tube teeth pulled and
get what's called a flipper tooth.
Just in case you don't know what that is
is basically a retainer. Yeah. My cousin,
he's attached to it.
That's going to run me about 450 bucks.
I basically want to know mommies.
What should I do?
What my Mommy's would do? Sorry.
I know Christina has always said,
put yourself in debt for your tea fees.
We already,
we are already paying an $8,000
hospital bill from 10 years ago.
What do I do? Jeans machine. How
expensive is it to repair? A crown.
I need help Mei, the tutes be
strong with you. The Nessa.
I'll tell you first of all, don't have
laid fixing those crowns are expensive.
Here's what you should do
if you can't afford it,
if you can't open up a line of credit,
ask for care credit. I believe it's,
it's a form of dental credit.
Your dentist's office may have that.
Go to a dental school.
Are you near a major city?
I recommend where near Ucla go to
UCLA and go to a dental student.
They can do it for a fraction of the
cost and you know the work will be
overlooked by whatever dentists
and such a that don't go cheap.
I don't, don't get the
flipper. I it looks like shit.
My cousin has a flipper
tooth with their retainer.
I don't think she hasn't anymore.
Oh No, I didn't think she,
I think she got replaced, but it, it
looks like it looks doesn't belong there.
So you know what I read it. Recommend
to me if you're paying off at that,
you said you don't want to accrue
all kinds of debt. One thing,
and this doesn't work obviously if
everybody, depending on your situation,
but a friend of mine did
this one time is that he,
this was before like sell a kidney, right?
Yeah. He's, he's, and he's sold a child,
uh, before Obama care and um, you know,
all those mandatory insurance things.
But this happened is that he,
he lapsed the payment on his insurance,
on his health insurance, lost it,
and then was in a kind of a bind,
obviously for health care.
And he went to doctor's
offices with cash and said,
could I get, because those doctor's
offices and dentist as well are used to,
you know,
maybe funneling some of this stuff through
insurance and they know they're only
getting a percentage of the
amount and all this stuff.
So he just went and was like, if I
pay you cash, can I get a discount?
And then he got,
he said yes across the board.
People were doing it for a fraction of
what they normally charge because he had
cash money. Oh. And I would say
if you have dental insurance, why?
I think if I've had it once before and
it's kind of a waste. And not only that,
the dentist,
I did take insurance one time I went
to and they took my x rays and they,
and the guy goes, oh, you have like
12 cavities. Remember this?
Yeah. And I go, that's horse
shit. I don't believe you.
I went to a dentist,
didn't tell them I had insurance and uh,
they took the same x rays and they go,
you have no cabinets? No, that was me. No,
that was me,
Babe.
Sure. Yeah, 100% sure. Are you sure
one? No. It happened to me too. No,
it did happen to me. And I've told
you this story. It happened to me.
I had dental insurance is
so weird. No, it happens.
It happened to me when I worked,
my God, it happened to me too.
Then there's a in Glendale
knew that it happened to you.
So here's when it happened to me.
Okay.
It happened to me,
happened to me too.
I swear to God was the
first time we're hearing,
I've told you this story multiple times.
I worked for the show extreme
makeover as a law. Right.
They let us go to the dentist to get
the zoom whitening treatment. Yeah.
When I was there, the x ray me and the
guy goes, oh, you have like 17 cavities.
And I was like, what? And I go, he's
like, yeah, you know, we'll, we'll,
we can take care of them
all now. And I go, I,
I think I'll take a range
of insurance at the time.
And that's why he was milking
you for dental insurance? Yes.
And so then I went to another dentist
that was covered under that dental
insurance and he was like, you have
no cavities to, you know, Ciro.
And I was blown away by it.
And then even though you know that
story that happened to you also,
did it happen?
Can I tell you why I had dental
insurance for the first time,
my life when I worked at this
company. Yeah. And I swear to God,
it was in Glendale and the guy goes, oh,
you got a lot of work to do. We got it.
I swear,
I believe you.
And then I took it to my Hungarian
guy who doesn't exist anymore.
He retired fire Dr for hair
and he's gotten, he's retired.
We can talk to him and he goes, there's
no way this guy was totally scamming you.
And then I canceled dental insurance
all together and just pay it.
So I would get a second opinion
is what I'm trying to say.
And the cavities on the cavities and on
the extent of the work that you need a
lot about it. Actually a
lot of times these scumbags
see that you have insurance,
I don't know, box. And then they
tried to get their money from,
you know, if it happened to both
of us, it can happen at the cabin.
Was it when I was working in Burbank
did we weren't dating then where we win,
the more you and I were dating, this
happened to me that this is a new story,
but oh my God, ask Eric. Eric,
if you're listening to this,
do you remember when this happened to me?
Because she'll be like, I remember
what happened at Tom. You're the worst.
And I remember, Oh, this
happened to you too. Okay,
got you. Laugh like an all
day. I hate you the most.
Ah, Shit. Anyway, why are
you have dental insurance?
Unless it comes with your company.
Don't pay for that shit.
There's no reason you're going to end up
getting jacked even harder. Check this.
Go to a Russian dentist.
Yeah, I swear to God.
Russians will do the work
a little bit cheaper too,
but we don't know where she lives.
Well,
find some fucking Russians or
eastern blockers. Foreigner.
I find a foreigner and I mean that.
Find a corner. Offer them cash. Yeah.
These white dentists, that's the problem
that they do everything above board.
You got to go to an immigrant to do shit
the right way. Yeah, go to Chinatown.
I didn't say that, but whoa.
Somewhere eastern bloc.
I can't vouch for the Chinese. Do they
have good teeth? Chinese people? Ah,
I don't know, but it just kinda feels
like words. I didn't say what I feel,
but I know for a fact that my
tribal do your teeth pretty good.
Russian eastern bloc.
They do. That shit will fuck you. Okay.
All right. Well maybe the Russians.
Uh Huh. Man, that was fucking good stuff.
I hate you so much. Why do you
hate me? It happened to me too.
I know it happened to you too. I
remember. Now you make me insane.
And I canceled dental insurance
right after, dude. Yes.
I think this is when we first
started dating. Well yeah,
go to somebody like that. That's that
neighbor and guys run mother fucker.
Go to that. My grandmother figure
and they'll tell you. Right.
And for a obviously car repairs
don't ever go to a white mechanic.
What are you nuts? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Always stay away from white people.
Immigrants stay away. Right?
Eastern bloc. Asians. Okay. Yeah.
That's a fear in la. I remember when
we went to get our um, Thai massages.
Yeah. They were like hookers after,
cause you went to a different one.
What happened was we,
so we moved to a new neighborhood and so
we have to do is to discover all kinds
of new stuff again. Right? New restaurants
and everything you use. That's the only,
you know,
it's kind of fun,
but it's also like bummed out if the
place he used to go to you liked. Yeah.
So we went to this Thai place together
like a few weeks ago and then we went
again and we called on the way they are
to request the same people that we had
the first time. Well, yours was available
for you, but mine wasn't. So I go, okay,
well I'll try whoever's
available. So we finish, uh,
the massage,
we go to the lobby and the,
the lady that they had me
the first time goes, oh,
she goes last time I go,
yeah, yeah. I asked for you.
And she looked at the girl that just
massage and she goes, yeah, he has for me.
And then she looked back at me and
she goes, so next time you meet again,
and I was like, oh,
okay. And the other lady,
you could tell that she was higher
up on the chain because the,
the lady that had just massage me, cat,
like put her head down and was like, ah,
totally
power to hurt. You just got involved in
hooker wars, dude. Yeah. Ty Hooker whores.
Welker wars massage. Hucker wars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. They totally,
she had you as her guy and then you
betrayed her. They see that. They see, he
just, you know, I think it's
a pride thing. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like that guy tips.
So yeah, that's mine. Yeah. They fucking
fight over you once you left, dude.
So who are you going to go with next time
we go back? I think I would go, it's,
you know, they're so different. The first
one massacres me, but I, I liked that.
I like,
how's the,
you know, what the end,
I'd never come a harder,
but the uh, the other lady,
petite hands, very small.
She's so ferocious though.
That first one really grinds
masturbated by a child. Right?
Oh my God. Little girl hand. Just
the thought of that fully erect,
but the second lady was a little more,
you know,
loving. You don't like that?
Well, it depends. I mean,
I tend to feel like if I had
to pick one all the time,
I would go for the really
aggressive and you like to be hurt.
You like to go and stop.
Yeah. You like that.
That gives you joy during them as well.
It's that joy. I feel like the others,
if it's less than that, I always feel
like nothing's happening. You have to,
it has to hurt to feel like
something's gotta be deep. Yeah. It's,
I feel about toothpaste if I
don't feel the burn of aqua fresh.
It's exactly like toothpaste.
Yes. It's exactly like toothpaste.
I know it's working cause it
burns your mouth. Yup. Yup.
How do you like soft touches though?
Right?
I like puppy touches you and like a
little puppy. I don't want to be heard.
Life hurts. I don't need to be hurt
in life arts. I don't need to be hurt.
She says, you know what I'm saying?
Took it to a whole other place. Yes.
You know what I mean? I go
to their language, to me,
I don't need her to beat
me up. Yeah. Palm with me.
I like my lady. She's,
she's a little chunky.
I got a little nervous when she got
on top of me. I was like, Oh fuck.
This bitch got on top of me. Once you
explain yourself well at the time,
his eyes day to day like sit on you.
She sits on my butt bones.
They put their knees on you and I
got real nervous. I'm like, bitch,
I just gave birth like, you
know, almost five months ago.
My body is not aligned yet.
My joints are still loose and
you know, we shoot sandwich. Oh,
I saw saw I t I a gentle.
I'm doing her accent. I know,
I know. What did she say?
No, seriously. She does what?
She's how she did it. I
was like, Oh no, I beats,
I stopped. The gentle,
gentle, gentle. She is,
she's tired and she did and she is gentle,
gentle,
and then she got on my ass
and I was like, Oh, you know,
I was nervous because she's real chunky.
You liked that,
but I liked the bup bones.
That's the past. That's good.
That's my, I wish you'd would
like an hour of just bub bones.
You could probably ask for it.
That's that culture is all
into just whatever you want.
And I like too that there's no modesty
and it's not like you're like a super
uptight white place. Like put your, put
these panties on and you're like, come on.
Yeah, I just get naked. And she
grazed my mal last time a little too.
She really raised, oh whoa.
You didn't want to touch.
You know they can go in there.
Did she grazer nuts. The nuts. It's so, it
is a lot. Like I'll be really
relaxed and then I will get,
because they're so
aggressive with me that I go,
I could really get a testicle hurt.
You know?
It's not like a,
Ooh.
It's like, yeah. So it's like, that's
usually where my eyes started to open.
Don't please take all my
testicles with. Yeah. Oh yeah,
they could. I bet they have.
Oh yeah, I sigh bowels.
What you're buying.
Yeah.
I saw I graze your bars. She
said, don't say that shit.
They never say that she doesn't know
balls. I don't know. Sorry. Yeah, yeah.
No, sorry man. No you don't. Yeah,
they don't do that shit. I'm
fine to be grazed. Yeah. We
should mention, by the way,
speaking of buyers is that,
um,
well first of all we should mention that
our patrion was going to launch first
June 1st. We will have patrion
which is going to be a,
an additional thing that the show does,
a added content added access,
bonus episodes,
bonus features, whole bunch of
stuff. June 1st we'll, we'll,
we'll get into the details
more as we get closer,
but we're building all that stuff right
now. We're very excited about it. Yeah.
So basically you make a monthly donation
of your choice and you get all this
extra content.
Yeah. So go to Patrion, create an
account, get it ready, get it ready. Okay.
The people, the people are there.
Start, start getting ready. Yeah.
Cause that's kind of guys, we already
have an episode. We have an idea for,
to do for patriots. Oh, there's gonna
be a lot of pretty cool. Yeah. Um,
we're planning our first one
already and then I'm all Pasha.
Pasha. That's not the Thai
place. That's Chinese,
right? No, that was tie them all Porsche.
Yeah. Awesome. They whisper it to you.
Yeah, I stopped you. Right.
A medium pressure dialing. Medium. Medium.
Awesome.
Where did the uh, hold on oven.
I was looking at the wrong thing.
Is this a
Oh, I, I go, I want to give a shout out
to a j hawk. I did. Um, the heart cast.
It drops today. It did come out
today. Yeah. So guys, check him,
check me out on Aja hogs podcasts.
Did you know that? He's a huge mommy.
I mean you didn't know that, but
people listening don't know that. Yeah.
Huge Mommy. Yeah. He listens to the show.
He loves our shell. He loves podcasts,
loves podcasts and he did it.
He's a great podcast or he's really good.
He's really good.
I was really surprised because you don't
think that like the guy that's good at
football is going to be good at talking,
but it is at foosball. Foosball.
We talked a lot about football.
You know the game stuff.
I have a podcast called charter
to the game, right. I talk about
sports and she mentioned that,
uh,
that my, um, new football
podcast, it to the game is out.
It's on iTunes and stitcher incidents.
That was mine. I know. Same as yours. Um,
episode two now that if you're
listening now just came out as well.
So two episodes up the newest one.
Uh,
we talk about the draft,
we talk about some NFL news and
we also have, uh, an interview,
a conversation I had with Travis
Johnson who used to play, uh,
for the chargers. Yeah.
The Texans and he's a,
a Florida state graduate,
um,
player and he went to high school right
around the corner from here. No kidding.
Yeah. Wow. Good for him. So yeah, I'm
really excited about that. And I'm also,
that's deep bro. Check out those deep
bro. High Caste. I talk about, um,
about Patti Smith this week and
Maple Thorpe and a identity,
you know, not just typical non
people of nonbinary issues,
just the kind of issues are you and I
as well? This is a very binary video.
It has a, a father and a,
I believe a daughter. Um,
and this is something we do every day
here. Yeah. Change dies. Oh No. Yeah.
Alright. Let's do this. Oh, Jesus.
You Ready? We'll change your bum.
That's how I do the change. When
you're ready buddy. Huh? Yeah.
That's a disaster every time.
[inaudible] up.
Yeah. Andrew, the straps. Dammit.
Tom. You know, I can't fucking
wait. It's fine. It's fine.
It's kind of Barb. No, he's
not going to Barf. He's not
going to borrow them. I can.
I can hear it.
It's fine to go.
It does make me, yeah, it
goes through this. Everyone.
Did he burn a little bit?
Well, he should wear a mask. Oh Man. I
felt like barfing look at his eyes. He's,
he's got tears in his eyes.
We haven't,
you felt like barfing doing
Ellis' a couple of times. Yeah,
I have dry heaves sometimes.
No,
but I've drive heats of number of times
where I'm like, whoa. Yeah, so bad.
And I feel like we're closer
to him because he's on
that, on the changing table.
Yeah. You're not that far really
from him thinking about it. Yeah.
Sometimes he has really crazy dumps. I
know sometimes you go like, oh, okay.
It's a little there and it doesn't
really have, but sometimes the,
they're massive and you really,
it hits you.
Sometimes I had to just give him a bath
right away. Yeah. I don't barely later,
maybe later this year you'll get
logs, which are, you know, the smell,
but I think it's going to be
different. Really. The died.
I feel like a little turds easier
to clown. Oh yeah, of course.
That's the slop is really his
pig slop dumps. Yeah. God. Yeah.
And they're green. Yeah.
Yeah. Snarly yeah, it looks
like, yeah. It like an animal.
This poor man. Yeah. Is it done or y'all?
Daniel finished your first year. I'd done,
yeah. Let me see what else we
got. See if I have something else.
I don't want to hear him bark. No, no.
I think I got just one other thing to
show you and y'all finish. Y'All done?
Y'all finished. Are
Y'all done? MMM. Sorry.
I just want to remind everybody,
please use our Amazon banner to do
your shopping. I didn't say it earlier.
Oh yeah, please, please.
It really does help the show
your mom's house high cast icon.
Go to the banner at the bottom
of the homepage. Click on that.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
Diverse. It's a mother
fucker. It's a supercar.
You're the worst.
What are you doing?
We're doing the show.
I don't even hear it turned mine down.
No, that's not yours. That's mine.
We're done. You're lying.
I just turned it off.
You're going to get it back
so fucking hard and we're
done. Pull your beard. Okay.
I'm going to teach Ellis to pull your
beard and your buddy. We're done.
You're lying to me and I know
I should. I close it. I did.
I closed blue band. Blue Band is the
one that helps you with this. Very true.
But,
but we're done now.
He's the one that introduced it to
him. You blamed bluebell in blame, mom.
I closed it. Okay. I promise. I
promise you can grab your headphones.
Everything's fine.
We're done the finish and we're done both.
We're both and trust you in the least.
Y'All are y'all finished? Are Y'all done?
We're done.
Ah,
you're fucking hell. I'm not. Smile.
I swear I'm done. I swear not done.
Sneaky. I'm not, I'm not. I promise
you you're going to fucking get it.
If I put my headphones on and
there's some horrible thing in there,
I'm telling you,
look,
I'll pull her tears tonight if I
have to hear something more Ramos.
Look, here's what we, I wanted to play
for you next. Okay? It's a commercial.
There's vomit. You're going to
fucking get it. There was no vomit.
Not going to touch your penis or for
a week. There's definitely no Bob,
no penis touching. I mean it, you fucking,
I won't touch it now.
We'll put it in my mouth for a year.
Okay, I'm ready for that question. The
trash in the trash now lies. It is.
Um,
you want mt touches on your penis then.
Don't ever play barf clips. Okay.
We're done with them forever.
Um, uh, check out though.
Vocal fry from this lady.
This mushroom foraging knife is made by
Radica or a company that has been hand
crafting brushes in Germany for over 75
years and is one of the last producer as
a lab.
You guys understand how pronounced
her vocal fry is? I mean it's like,
uh,
it's a deliberate,
the more that I learned about vocal fry,
the thing that stands out and
that is a deliberate action.
People are learning and
then repeating a forced,
uh,
vocal
affectation. Uh, yeah.
It's because people like,
I know it's because of the
cart dash the Kardashians.
They talk like that and then people,
then they ended up talking
like that themselves.
But it's not natural to be like they been
making these handcraft the artifacts,
knives and brush hose,
not how you talk about,
I usually it usually
it does go with a girl.
I was talking a lot
about a lot of Charles,
it has been handcrafting
brushes in Germany for over
75 years and is one of the
last producers of handmade fresh ideas
are coming from a sustainably source,
would handle a stinky hot lead and
have belts in pig bristle brush pipe.
It is not only an ideal tool for foraging
mushrooms, but also to clean them.
She looks a little mind blowing dirt away
from mushrooms is better than rinsing
them.
Or I'd say, who the fuck has time
to do this to their mushrooms?
I always pay by ability to pay your
mushroom and then use a special carving to
like fuck off. Who's got time? Well,
actually I started studying could day.
I bet he paints his mushrooms.
You pay your mushrooms, but
yeah, it's a metaphor, right? Paint in
your restrooms. It's great. Yeah. Uh,
can I see what she does with
these mushrooms though? I'm
curious now. She didn't,
that's it. Yeah. We
just had the vocal fry,
that's all my master
painter mushrooms.
I paint my mushrooms.
You're not every fucking day.
I wake up at 5:00 AM before
the baby's loot the sun,
and then I paint my mushrooms.
Uh,
um, so we have, uh, something that,
what's been in the,
in the,
uh,
been in the jeans kind of
machine here for awhile.
I, one of the all time greats.
I think maybe one of my,
it's gotta be one of my
favorite artists of all time.
And that would be the great Rihanna.
Also the Great Mozart, you
know, I'm a big mom. It's hard,
I think you mean mom's, sorry.
And I are very, very tight. Um,
I play a lot of his songs.
What's up?
Is it a Mozart in that folder?
Um, well let me check. I don't trust
you guys. Something smells fishy. No,
it's not fishing. I promise. I promise
it's not, but I have it. I have it saved.
Thank you. A blue band, everybody.
Uh, and maybe when you do patriotic,
we can do a blue band episode
where we can get introduce. Yeah.
Um, people are like, who's blue band?
Well, he's a fucking bird. Okay.
Um, anyways, um, seeds,
he needs seeds on a new mirror for
his cage. He likes to look at himself.
Did you know
that
at birds or is those silly?
Mozart was really into anal Lingus.
I did. He wrote a song about it. Yes. Um,
so we have some of this stuff here,
some of his lyrics and some of his songs.
Um,
we've been dying to play it for you.
My ass,
my ass.
That wasn't him,
but that's just kind of the,
the world that he's in. Um, you
understand what I'm saying? Are,
you know what I'm talking about? Do
you understand? Okay. Here we go.
Okay. Yeah. Let me, let me,
let me see what
sound.
Oh, fuck me in my ass.
Know how great is that?
20,000 years ago
you were writing
songs about
22,500 years.
Here's what's going on. Here's the
translation. Lick me in the ass.
Let us be glad.
Grumbling is in vain.
Groundling droning is in vain,
is the true cross of the life,
thus less does let us be glad
and Mary Pretty Great, right?
It's great. Yeah. I've,
I've read about this before.
It's a little ditty that he wrote.
He also was known to be very sexual
in nature with his letter writing.
Here's a letter that
he wrote to his cousin.
Wouldn't you like to visit
hair? Goldsmith again? What for?
Nothing. Just one choir, I guess
about the Spoonie Goonie fate.
Nothing else. Nothing else.
Long live. All those who,
how does it go on? I wish you
were. I now wish you a good night.
Shit in your bed with all your might.
Sleep with peace on your mind and try
to kiss your own behind. I love it.
I would have really liked
your mom's house. I think he
would have been a big fan.
Yeah.
Tip the hat to you Sir Mam.
Sorry. Yeah. So this is um,
I mean one of the greatest musical
minds ever isn't a shitting and wrote a
beautiful song about, oh yeah. I mean
we could probably get acquired as
things as not know what they're doing.
That's a really funny idea. Actually.
Get them to sing it and be like,
here's what you saying.
I love it.
I love it too.
Need to know that. And He, yeah, he
was a bit of a perv. That's cool.
Yeah. Yeah. He had a lot of, of uh,
apparently at more than one song about
the ass and ass eating. Yeah. Lick my ass.
Yes. Very good. Very, very good.
Very talented man. That guy
my ass late.
Another day there.
Similar, similar, maybe not with the
music, but certainly a performer.
The penis music. Yeah. One
of your favorites for sure.
I love Rocco and I go way back.
So anyways,
great discussion with him. We got to
wrap this show. Hey sticks on deck.
600 deck. We've got a lot of
that. Um, where was it? Oh,
it was texts. Texted deal.
So I got a rogue text message from,
you know,
I got this new phone number about a year
ago and now I just, I get random texts.
Random voicemails. Yeah. And
someone just wrote sticks on deck.
We mentioned that last week and
we've got a lot of messages, a lot,
some of them very insulting. I'm
saying, how could you not know that?
And then how could you name yeah,
how could you not know that?
And then 10 different versions
of what they think it meant.
A lot of people said like the Xanax,
then I got Xanax.
Right. Uh, then people said do 600
deck is guns. There's guns here.
I have guns for sale. Okay.
No, then people said, uh, yeah,
sticks on deck set. Like I wrote, dude,
obviously it's a photographer. Uh,
dicks are tripods, so it's like
we're ready to shoot sticks on deck.
They're ready to go. Okay.
That was a likely, um, not,
not very, I don't know. No.
Look. So I think it's drugs.
So we had Xanax guns.
Um,
a tripod and then somebody
was like, no, it's money,
but that's stacks and stacks. Stacks are
not sticks. Yeah. He had sticks on deck.
Right. It sticks on Day. Yeah. So
why would, yeah, I think it's a typo.
And there was like, oh, he's got
his money. He's got all his money.
Here's why.
Cause this phone number also gets
tweets a text about gambling too from,
I think a similar, really the number. So
it's like, hey, there's action on blah,
blah blah, or whatever. So
it's drugs and it's gambling.
And that makes sense because eight is
the, who this is a problem, has a problem.
Adas was mia and his
family was living in Rehab.
He was in Rehab is shrink was
looking for him one time. Adas. Yeah.
He ran from his family. So
he, I think it's atus. Hmm.
Interesting.
I know since Shenaz with all her
nursing job, she's not getting,
and then the Persian a person.
Yeah. The Persian person.
I forget what their name is.
That's what I'd say personally.
I don't want to use the wrong
pronoun or something. June.
June. Yeah. Joan. Joan. No, Shanna.
Mm. Okay. Um, all right, so this is, uh,
let's see, I got to look at
my cheat sheet. Assholes,
my ass home. This is by Anthony. He's,
Oh my God. Anthony Heath
data. I know, I know. I know.
I didn't think that it
was happening right now,
but those are the [inaudible] nine.
Hey, don't forget the bike shirt.
Please go to Tom [inaudible] dot com
people are loving the bike shirt.
Please get that, uh,
support your genes. Anthony,
he here with the closing song.
I'll let him set it up and take it away.
Jeans,
anything else you want to mention
before we go listen to that Steve Brown?
Uh Huh.
Listen to charter to the game and listen
to that steep bro. Yes, please do.
All right, thanks guys. Thanks
mommies. Bride, mommies.
Okay.
Hey Hitler.
It's Anthony.
Okay.
My and I were talking
earlier and we noticed some,
okay.
Some more troubling pattern
in the community. Um,
although the,
your mom's house community has come
together to accept all poly and by people,
which I am both. Um, there's been a,
an outline group that
really is unrepresented.
And even just sometimes,
um,
I came out to my father at 15 as
an acoustic singer songwriter,
and I just thought I should
work on something to really
bring the community back
together and, uh, and the rift, so,
and
little kids,
whoa.